[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
is it finally time to declare antifa a
domestic terror group is it finally time
for the left to condemn and tifa's use
of violence and intimidation and is it
finally time for the liberal media to
call out and Tifa strident violations of
civil and human rights
[Music]
crosstalking antifa I'm joined by my
guest Jen Kearns in New York she's a GOP
strategist as well as founder of women
for a great America in Austin we have
Daniel Bona back he is professor of
philosophy in human dimensions of
organizations at the University of Texas
at Austin as well as a contributor to
News Max and in Budapest we cross to
George Samuli he's the author of bombs
for peace NATO's war on Yugoslavia all
right crosstalk rules in effect that
means he can jump in anytime you want
and I always appreciate it
George let me go to you first in
Budapest one's very simple opening
question is an Tifa a domestic terror
group well I think so by all the
criteria that we measure terrorist
groups it basically has one agenda which
is to use violence against its political
opponents it its political opponents it
identifies extremely broadly it has no
legislative agenda it has no kind of
coherent electoral agenda its sole
reason d'etre is the use of violence and
to create as much mayhem on the streets
of the United States as possible Jan the
same question to you and I'm really glad
that George added that because that what
is the agenda it the means and the ends
are the same violence that's terror
go ahead Jay right absolutely in fact if
you look up the FBI's definition of
terror and a terror organization they
fit this bill to a tee it says that
they're there any group that seeks to
further their own political or religious
ideology by the use of violence or force
should be declared a domestic terror
group and under those definitions that
that is correct and look if you look at
the other couple of groups over time
over the last you know decade or so that
have been declared domestic terror
organizations in the United States and
Tifa is actually more violent so look at
the Weather Underground which bill ayers
the former advisor to Barack Obama was
involved in The Weather Underground
laid bombs that were intended for
policemen and not even a single person
died yet The Weather Underground is on
the FBI's list of domestic terror
organizations you also look at another
group at the environmental Liberation
Front known as e.l.f or elf they're the
group that set fire to a bunch of estate
properties and condominiums and car
dealerships in the state of California
where I hail from and and again nobody
was killed or injured in those but the
environmental Liberation Front was
declared a domestic terror group so
under these same same standards Auntie
fush should absolutely be declared a
domestic terror group one of my clients
and II know the journalist who was
attacked two weeks ago in Portland
Oregon is suffering a great fate from
that he has a severe brain hemorrhage a
head injury and probably some long-term
problems from that so by all definitions
that seems to fit yes Daniel I'm glad
that Andy was brought up here it's all
films it's patently obvious what
happened to him he didn't even defend
himself and with the exception of a few
places in media it was just brushed
aside and on top of it you have CNN
coddling these groups coddling their
members coddling their weapons on camera
and giving them moral support I mean
this is a terror group and you have the
mainstream media backing them up it's
it's this is extraordinary
this is how societies fall apart by the
way go ahead Daniel in Austin I agree
with you it is how societies fall apart
there has been an amazing alteration you
might say my understanding is that the
FBI began looking into this group in
2016 before the election so it was under
the Obama administration
but ever since Trump has been elected
and Trump has become one of the enemies
of the group it turns out that certain
media organizations like CNN have in
effect changed their stripes on this
they were quite concerned about this
until about 2017 and all of a sudden
they started thinking well maybe an Tifa
is
so bad enemy of our enemy is our friend
this type of thing but I am shocked
because I agree with you this is the
kind of thing that breaks societies down
you start with the claim that oh we're
just targeting a few extremist groups
that are also prone to violence and this
is just defense but pretty soon you have
people like and ago who are caught in
the middle who are not extremists by any
definition there is a group on our
campus that is roughly loosely
affiliated with antifa they have a list
of professors who they consider enemies
of the people I'm on that list but a
bunch of people are on that list one of
the most outspoken leftists on campus is
on that list so it's completely unclear
to me what you have to do to count as a
fascist or racist or someone else that
they target it's extremely broadly
conceived and more or less anyone they
don't like for any reason go ahead gen
jump in that's the point of the program
chaplain Peter Peter Daniel he makes a
great point you know no one here is
really sufficient enough for antifa and
the real goal in the end is complete
anarchy so so now they're going after
the right but as you just heard they're
going after some folks on the left if
you're not liberal enough you might fit
that enemies of the people list and look
here's what we have to do to solve the
problem you know they say that politics
and politics money is the mother's milk
and so we have to find out where this
group is being funded and we have to
choke off that funding source and look
as Daniel just said there they're not
going to be happy until they have
complete anarchy it doesn't matter if
you're on the right or the left if
you're Alexandria Ocasio Cortes you
might be friends with them now and in
the case of the the Portland March we
did see them watch walking with you know
members of the DSA the Democratic
socialists of America those are a oh C's
people but at some point
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes might not be
liberal enough for them or anarchic
enough for them George I mean it seems
like what they really want because you
know they they're going after the entire
spectrum of the politics there they
really want intimidation they want
people
to be intimidated they want people to be
silenced they want people to actually
disappear in public meaning not go out
in public this is really intimidation
here and and and I think Jen just
pointed out here it's just only gonna
get worse as it has gotten worse since
2016 when I mean in Portland Oregon
you've seen the video I mean they just
take over the center of the city and the
police say okay fine we don't want to
get involved well whatever whatever
happen to the legitimate use of force by
the state when you abrogate that you
give it to someone else maybe help will
use it in a very different way they will
intimidate you George you no question
that is exactly what they're doing it's
using force to stop meetings that they
don't like it's known as Lee the
hecklers veto yeah you know somebody
wants to listen to somebody's views
somebody's speech okay we will just
disrupt it and you won't get to listen
to whomever you want to listen to so
yeah however what has to say it's it's
not an agenda that will in the end
succeed because it's actually I mean
chief is one of a number of anarchist
groups that are springing up in the US
and the UK in other places and whenever
you have anarchists I mean you know what
is reminded of what Lenin said about
Alec is I mean the after all that was
also a big problem in the late 19th
century the other socialists didn't know
how to deal with the anarchists which is
that these are people who are just nuts
I mean they are opportunists they use
violence recklessly and they are
self-destructive they play into the
hands of their opponents I mean sooner
or later the public is going to get
tired of brawling in the streets I mean
and and at that moment the the public
will turn to some authoritarian figure
to bring the chaos to an end I mean
remember in the 1960s when there was
also a considerable amount of violence
in society what does that lead to
Republicans winning five of the next six
presidential elections and that that's
the that's the
and result of this you know Daniel I
mean it's all come from the universities
why is that okay I mean I left academia
because I didn't like the political
correctness and that was actually like
two decades ago I mean it's only gotten
far far worse but it seems it's all
incubated on the campuses oh by the way
which are funded by American taxpayers
okay so the incubation is paid for by
the American public which which antiva
has absolutely contempt for go ahead in
Austin well you're right about that
what's happening on campuses it started
happening in a very strong way in the
90s early 90s I you saw that firsthand
it's gotten much worse now it's that on
steroids and the difference is that it's
not just that the faculty has drifted
further and further to the left on some
campuses now the ratio of people on the
Left to people on the right is something
like a hundred and twenty one yeah but
in addition to that you've got offices
in the administration offices of
diversity and inclusion they're often
called that have is their mission
cracking down on speech and that lend
support to these groups maybe not
official support but they're the ones
who are taking them seriously on our
campus of 50,000 students they're maybe
25 50 students who might be affiliated
with these radical groups but the
administration listens to them and so
they have a power far out of proportion
to their numbers all it takes is one
student in the thousand but some
sympathetic administrators to make that
voice seem very powerful and to silence
other people okay I'm gonna stay with
you do to be probably go to the break
these sounds let this smoke hang on let
me stay with Daniel it sounds like these
people like the red guard or they would
have been very happy working under Pol
Pot go ahead 30 seconds before we go to
the break go ahead I think that's
exactly the analogy and my ideas of the
20th century course I now teach the Red
Guards because I want people to see that
parallel that is what it's like in fact
my only objection to the declaration of
this group as a domestic terror
organization is that I'm not sure it's
very organized it seems to be highly
decentralized there really isn't much of
any leadership that can anyone can
discern so
to say who's in the group and who's out
of it but it does seem to me that it's
like the Red Guards in a sense
self-organizing given official support
and then the officials turn up a blind
eye to whatever they do and they can
they get they get media support okay I'm
gonna jump in here we're gonna go to a
short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on a tithi
stay with Artie welcome back to
crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter LaBelle to remind
you were discussing antifa
[Music]
okay let's go back to Jen in New York
it's fascinating what Daniel said before
we went to the break here they he
described it as being decentralized but
I suppose the only thing that really
kind of polarizes everyone in one
direction one way or another is Donald
Trump and you know I remember after the
election in 2016 the riots that went
across the country and the violence and
destruction of private property and in
the media was covering it with a great
Glee you know it's like this is a
wounded people people are afraid but no
no CNN and MSNBC they just they just
fueled it on they were they were gas
lighting the entire public and they
continued to do it
III have to agree with George at one
point in time CNN and MSNBC they will be
the target to when the red guards come
out here so you know how much is Donald
Trump have to do with this I mean
eventually you know if Trump when Trump
leaves the scene whenever that is if
it's in a year and a half or four more
years
I mean is this what really kind of
incubates these these movements here is
there's blind hatred of Donald Trump and
everything that he's associated with
like borders for example which you know
I think are absolutely necessary if you
want to have a nation-state you need to
have it and and if you don't you know
have a OSI around then the whole world
that will have its health care paid by
the American people okay go ahead we
could talk that we could talk about the
campaign later
go ahead Jen how is Trump playing
essential role in this well I do agree
that you know the election of Donald
Trump did spark and Tifa but you know as
you said it's Donald Trump today it
could be CNN tomorrow could be Nancy
Pelosi the day after that look AOC is
already turning against Nancy Pelosi in
her own caucus so they have their own
set of problems but but going back to
what daniel said about the this activity
really being incubated on college
campuses that is a great point and and
so far they seem to think that their
stakeholders are these as daniel said
fifty to a hundred students of diversity
and inclusion but I'll tell you how
that's going to change you look at
what my clients were able to accomplish
at the UC Berkeley University of
california-berkeley one of the most
liberal college campuses during that
ante fuh attack over some conservative
speakers a year or two ago this group
was able to actually get a settlement
out of UC Berkeley for about a hundred
thousand dollars because they they
allowed these liberal protestors to set
fire to things and to bar conservative
students inside the campus building
while the campus police stood by and
watched and the only thing that's going
to change here is people holding these
universities to account because their
bottom line is important to them and
once these universities have to start
paying out these big settlements because
they stood by as conservative students
were beaten up and bloodied in the
streets that's when the situation's
going to change and I think UC Berkeley
was the first case of that and I think I
don't know this for sure but I think
there's a lawsuit coming against
Portland
in case of Andy node that will be very
interesting yep and I hope he gets his
justice and I hope he goes to the bank
okay I saw that video from multiple
angles I was so disgusted by it
absolutely disgusted by it where's the
humanity why no one helped him here I
mean he had to go to the police himself
know and I don't know I'm getting a very
emotional matter because I'm really
upset because I've seen him interviewed
before this here is an upstanding person
doing his job as a journalist very few
actually do their job as a journalist
these days George who are these people
you know I mean because if they're
wearing a black mask what's the
difference between a black mask in a
white hood of the KKK can you explain
the difference to me not really and it
is outrageous that they're allowed to
wear masks in public that particularly
when they're taking part in
demonstrations I mean that but that
should be outlawed right away in fact
the police should have just simply
stopped them wearing masks and wearing
that kind of black uniforms smacks of
militia and again the public should not
the police should not tolerate that kind
of thing at all
and again just shows how the police have
fallen down on their job but what is
interesting though is the point hasn't
already been raised is how weak the
universities of them yeah and how they
are not being held to account by
governments I mean look at what happened
in Oberlin I mean they they lost that a
lawsuit that was filed against the
university because they tried to bring
this poor Baker Drive this poor Baker
out of business huge I mean the court
really hit the university because the
court thought the university behaved
outrageously and it did yeah they didn't
rage ously behavior yeah absolutely
and obviously the court was just furious
about the fact that the professors and
administrators were actually egging on
and taking part in these student
protests trying to drive a decent old
business out from the city and has there
been any kind of repercussions for any
of the administrators you know the
president of the university you know if
you're in the state government I mean
you should know we should just have to
do something about this I mean you can't
just allow universities to behave in
this sort of thuggish manner you know
Daniel I mean I I'm I don't know how
well you can answer this question but
maybe you can speculate I mean I mean if
it's coming from the campuses here I
mean what kind of people are they I mean
they cover their face are these middle
class kids are they prevent primarily
people of color are they white are they
bored they're looking for their
revolution I mean it happens very often
when you have a class of people that are
quite affluent and don't have to worry
too much they they they want to play
they want to play out their life they
want to act out okay and you know when
you look at you know from the 60s when
we had the civil rights movement and
then we had acceptance of alternative
sexual preferences I mean we've had a
lot of things happen over the last 50
years here are they looking for their
thing it's to burn it to the ground is
that what it's all about I mean are they
bored
go ahead Daniel it's a it's a good
question
and since they wear masks and since the
membership of the group is very fluid
it's hard to answer that question I
think it's striking that the person who
attacked the ice facility in Seattle was
62 years old this was not a student and
so with these student groups you have a
lot of people who were affiliated
loosely part of various left-wing and
anarchist groups who helped the students
out and egg them on and vice versa so
it's a weird constellation of people on
campus and off campus and my only
information about this really is from
some students who know students in the
group here at the University of Texas
and what they tell me is that these are
mostly white usually quite affluent kids
very bright but without much direction
in their lives yeah privilege certain
radical thinkers a lot of privilege a
lot of privilege and the people we've
seen arrested a few are black a few are
Hispanic but the overwhelming majority
are white and a significant number are
older than student age 2 but my sense is
that these people are pretty much the
same people you find in the Palestinian
solidarity committee and a variety of
other groups in fact on our campus there
are official groups there is the
unofficial radical group and what I've
been told by students who know some of
these people is that it's more or less
the same people at all the groups so I
think one way to rancer the question
more precisely is to say some of the
more organized of the groups whose in
them and I think you're right it's
mostly upper middle class kids who are
radicalized at some point along the way
overwhelmingly white not themselves at
all the product of some kind of
disadvantage or harm and what attracts
them to the radical ideas I think they
need something to give meaning to their
lives and they don't have anything else
yeah yeah well I grew up poor I didn't
need to have a college I just wanted to
get an education and get a job okay
that's all I needed
I'm a pretty simple guy okay Jenn I mean
I mean if you see these these people and
TP
acting out their terrorist acts here I
mean FoxNews of course covers it very
well and I appreciate that they do but I
mean and and actually more people watch
Fox News for their news than any other
network it's I must admit I think the
the the public is outraged that what
happened to Andy and and in the again
this coddling of the liberal media I I
think the Heartland is good saying as I
said in my introduction you know it's
time and nothing is enough of this here
and I do you think it will turn into a
political issue for the 2020 election
well it doesn't appear to be an issue on
the Democrat side
what's interesting Peter of course you
don't see you don't see any member of
the Democratic Party
no member of the Democratic Party that
I'm aware of came out and can and and it
chastise the group for the attack on
Andy I think that is is deafening that
silence is deafening and here's the
other interesting thing the deflection
here is very interesting because you
always hear liberals talk about how
Republicans are are the party of toxic
masculinity but here you have parties
aligned with the left in this country
including the Socialists literally out
there in the streets angry white
privileged males beating people to a
pulp in the street that is the
definition of toxic masculinity and
third to George's point here about the
the masks is a black hood the same as a
white hood yes and in fact the u.s.
actually has a law on its books that
prohibits this it's called the Klan act
and it was certain it was passed during
the era of the KKK it says that you
cannot wear a mask in the street during
a protest the people who are responsible
for that
got that on the books thankfully some
good leaders got that on the books a few
decades back but look if the law
enforcement on the street is not
upholding those laws there's virtually
nothing you can do about it and that's
the alarming thing so the police have
got to uphold the books the laws on the
books and that includes the Klan Act
which says no masks no helmets nothing
to prevent your identity
we don't do that in the United States of
America okay George last 40 seconds here
they wearing a mask as they're ashamed
of what they're doing that's why they're
wearing it
they have no courage no guts George
right no exactly and to your question
will it play a role in the presidential
election yeah I'm sure it will I'm sure
that Trump will get a lot of mileage out
of it and the Democrats are being
extremely foolish by failing to distance
themselves from anti-fur and from the
violence and intolerance because this is
going to be wrapped around their necks
in the during the election campaign yep
it was definitely good to be a boomerang
I really hope the best for Andy and his
legal defense I hope he gets justice and
actually please tell him I'd like to
meet him and have him on my program
that's all the time we have here many
thanks to my guests in new york austin
and in budapest and thanks to our
viewers for watching us here at RT see
you next time and remember crosstalk
rules
[Music]